اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وزير خارجيه
السعوديه في موسكو بعد كييف وروسيا ترحب
بوساطه سعوديه لحل الازمه في اوكرانيا
وزير الدفاع الام
ريكيين بينهما على التصدي لتهديدات ايران
النوويه
الشهيد هذا
[تصفيق]
ازمه جورجيا امريكا مع الشارع وروسيا مع
الحكومه والاخيره تسحب مشروع قانون اشعل
الصدمات في البلاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
موجه جديده من الاضرابات تضرب فرنسا ردا
على اقرار مجلس الشيوخ لرفع سن التقاعد
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من زياره وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
الى موسكو التقى بنظيره الروسي طبعا هذه
الزياره تاتي في غضون اسبوعين فقط من
زياره مماثله قام بها وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الى الامير فيصل بن فرحان اكد ان
المملكه جاهزه للقيام بما يلزم لحل الصراع
في اوكرانيا ومن جانبه رحب لافروف بموقف
السعوديه مؤكدا انها تسعى لايجاد حل مناسب
للازمه نتابع
نسعى دائما لدعم كل ما من شانه
الوصول الى تسويه لهذا الصراع ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق انساهمنا
فيما
حصل في من تبادل السجناء
والذي اشرف عليه سموه العهد مباشره بتعاون
مشكور من الجانب الروسي
وسنستمر في البحث عن الفرص المتاحه
لتسهيل الحوار بين الطرفين
تطرقنا لمناقشه عده قضايا في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا موسكو ورياض متفقهان على ان
الحل السياسي هو الافضل لكل القضايا
العالميه بمشاركه جميع الاطراف نحن نقدر
عمل اصدقائنا في السعوديه والدور الذي
تلعبه المملكه في المنطقه
مراسله العربيه كاتيا اهلا بك كاتيا اذا
استمعنا بهذه التصريحات موسكو ترحب
بواساطه سعوديه تقول بانه الدور السعودي
ليس فقط مقتصر على تبادل الاسرى ولكن يمكن
ان يكون اكثر من ذلك ما الذي تسعى اليه او
تتوقع موسكو من السعوديه
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل اليوم خلال المؤتمر
الصحفي بين الوزيرين الروسي ووزير خارج
السعودي كان قد تطرق وزير خارجيه لافروف
الى ان دور السعودي في الازمه الاوكرانيه
هو ليس يقتصر فقط على الدور الانساني
والذي شهدناه من خلال عمليات تبادل الاسرى
المتكرره كما قال واشاد به الرئيس عفوا
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ولكن ايضا قال ان
المملكه قادره ايضا ان تلعب ادوار اخرى في
الازمه الاوكرانيه وليس فقط بموضوع
الانسان طبعا لم يتم التوضيح عن اي ادوار
بالضبط ولكن هو قال ان السعوديه قادره ان
تكون كوسيط في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه ولكن
ما يعيق حل هذه الازمه هو طبعا الجانب
الاوكراني الذي هو طبعا كما قال وقع رئيس
اوكراني على قرار يمنع خوض اي مباحثات مع
الجانب الروسي طبعا كان الوزيران لقد بحث
ليس فقط الازمه الاوكرانيه بحث عده مواضيع
من اهمها طبعا موضوع الطاقه واستمرار
التنسيق على التنسيق على اعلى مستوى بين
الجانبين في
اطار صيغه
والتي اعتبرها طبعا مهمه لانها تلعب دور
في استقرار
الطاقه في العالم بالاضافه لذلك كانت
تتطرقها ايضا الى ملفات الشرق الاوسط من
بينها الازمه في سوريا وامكانيه كما تحدث
عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه بعد الزلزال الذي وقع
هناك ايضا اشاد بالدول السعودي في ارسال
العمليات او المساعدات الانسانيه الى
سوريا كما تطرقها ايضا الى القضيه
الفلسطينيه وازمه في اليمن وامكانيه حلها
والدوره الروسي والدور السعودي ايضا في حل
هذه الازمات جميعها ميسون طيب دعيني اعود
للعلاقه الروسيه السعوديه فيما يتعلق
بالملف الاوكراني وزير الخارجيه كان في
اكياف قبل اسبوعين قدمت السعوديه مساعدات
انسانيه قيمه الكياف كيف تنظر موسكو الى
مثل هذه التحركات والى اي حد
تتقبل فكره ان يكون هناك نوع من الموازنه
بين العلاقات بين الجانبين
اول ما تحدث عنه وزير الخارجيه الروسي سبق
ميسون هو عن الدور المتوازن للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
والموقف المتوازن من الازمه الاوكرانيه
طبعا هو لم يتطرق عن المساعدات الانسانيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه التي تقدمتها
الى اوكرانيا هو اشاد في الدوري والموقف
المتوازن للمملكه من ناحيه هذا الملف
والذي طبعا تلعبه المملكه من خلال عده
جهات من بينها كما تحدثت ايضا عمليه
التبادل الاسرع التي ساعدت بها المملكه
وبالاضافه الى دول عربيه وايضا كانت قد
قدمت دور الوساطه معين بهذا الملف ادى الى
عمليات تبادل اسرى مختلفه ومتكرره كانت
اخرها كنا قد شهدناها منذ يومين كانت قد
تبادلت روسيا مع اوكرانيا
استرجعت 90 جندي روسي كانوا قد تم اسرهم
في السجون الاوكرانيه ميسون مراسلات
العربيه كاتيا شكرا جزيلا لك
من التطورات السياسيه الى اخر التطورات
الميدانيه طبعا المتعلقه بالحرب في
اوكرانيا والتي تدخل عامها الثاني الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت عن تدمير كل المواقع
المستهدفه في اوكرانيا خلال ضربه واسعه تم
تنفيذها اليوم الدفاع الروسيه قالت بان
الضربه استهدفت جميع مواقع البنى التحتيه
والحيويه التابعه للجيش الاوكراني ردا على
هجوم براينس الاسبوع الماضي حيث تم
استخدام اسلحه عاليه الدقه بما في ذلك
صاروخ فنجال الفرد صوتي ونتيجه الضربه
المكثفه تم احباط نقل قوات اوكرانيه
واسلحه غربيه عبر خطوط السكك الحديد بحسب
الدفاع الروسيه
طبعا مشاهدينا نتيجه للقصف الروسي المكثف
هذا الصباح الذي تحدثنا عنه اكدت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التابعه للامم
المتحده اكدت ان امدادات الكهرباء انقطعت
عن محطه زابوريجيا لاول مره منذ نوفمبر
العام الماضي اشارت الى ان المحطه باتت
تعتمد على مولدات تعمل بالديزل فقط وهو خط
دفاع اخير لمنع الانصهار الناتج عن ارتفاع
درجه حراره وقود المفاعل
ميدانيا في باخم التحديدا لا تزال المعارك
جاريه فيما تسيطر روسيا رويدا رويدا على
المزيد من المدن حيث اعلن قائد قوات فاجنر
شبه العسكريه الروسيه
اعلن السيطره على بلده
الواقعه في شمال غرب ضباخ طبعا هذا يعد
اول تقدم للقوات الروسيه في المحور
الشمالي الغربي للمدينه بعد السيطره على
الجانب الشرقي على كل الرغم اشتداد
المعارك ترفض القوات الاوكرانيه الانسحاب
من مواقعهم على جبهات القتال نتابع اطلقنا
النار من الموقع الخفي على مواقع العدو
وتم اصابتها الجنود بوضع جيد ستبقى صامده
وسننتصر
رئيس المخابرات العسكريه الليتوانيه ان
روسيا لديها ما يكفي من موارد لمواصله
الحرب في اوكرانيا وذلك لمده عامين اشار
الى ان الموارد التي تمتلكها روسيا في
الوقت الحالي ستكون كافيه لمواصله الحرب
بنفس الوتيره لمده عامين مضيفا ان طول
الفتره التي يمكن لروسيا فيها شن الحرب
يعتمد ايضا على الدعم الذي يتلقاه الجيش
الروسي من دول مثل ايران وايضا كوريا
الشماليه
ومع الشداد المعارك على الارض والخسائر
البشريه التي يتكبدها الطرفان في الحرب
الروسي وايضا الاوكراني باتت التعبئه
العسكريه ازمه ظهرت في روسيا ثم يبدو انها
انتقلت الى اوكرانيا الان لا سيما مع عدم
وجود امال بانهاء الصراع في المستقبل
المنظور وذلك بحسب صحيفه
مع اشتداد المعارك في شرقي اوكرانيا كثفت
كييف انشطه التعبئه العسكريه في الشهرين
الاولين من 2023
الجيش الاوكراني يحتاج الى مزيد من القوات
لمواكبه المعارك وتدفق الاسلحه التي
يقدمها الغرب
نيوزويك خدمه الامن الاوكرانيه حجبت 26
قناه على تيليجرام يعتقد انها تساعد من هم
في سن التجنيد على تجنب التعبئه
نيوزويك ماركات جامعه جورج مصر
استراتيجيه اوكرانيا الان تكمن في استدعاء
اكبر عدد من المجندين للتعبئه مع استمرار
الحرب
مجله الايكونوميست الوضع في اوكرانيا سبقه
الامر نفسه في روسيا التي استدعت 300 الف
جندي سابق في سبتمبر 2022
فرار اكثر من 300 وسبعين الف روسي من
البلاد في الاسبوعين الذين اعقب مرسوم
بوتين للتعبئه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
تظاهرات حاشده في اسرائيل ضد خطه تغيير
النظام القضائي وننتظر مؤتمر صحفي لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي مع نظيره الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا نكمل الخامسه من جوله وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه الى الشرق الاوسط في
اسرائيل الاعربه اوستن عن التزام الولايات
المتحده بعدم السماح لايران بامتلاك سلاح
نووي بيان للبنتاجون ذكر ان اوستن ناقش مع
نتنياهو التحديات الامنيه الاقليميه ومن
بينها الملف النووي الايراني والعواقب
المميته لتوسيع التعاون العسكري الروسي مع
ايران اوستن دعا الى وقف الاجراءات
الاحاديه الجانب التي تقود هدف اقامه
دولتين يتمتع فيهما الفلسطينيون
والاسرائيليون بتدابير متساويه كما شدد
ايضا على اهميه الالتزام باتفاقات العقبه
مع زياره اوستن خرجت تظاهرات حاشده في
اسرائيل احتجاجا على خطه حكومه نتنياهو
لتغيير النظام القضائي مراسله العربيه
اشارت الى ان 60 الفا من المتظاهرين
تجمعوا بالتزامن مع وصول وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الى اسرائيل وقد اغلق المتظاهرون
بطرق السريعه المؤديه الى المطار قبل
مغادره نتنياهو الى روما
دون منع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو من السفر الى ايطاليا بسبب ما
يعرف بتغيير نظام القضائي وقاموا بعرقله
حركه السير داخل شوارع المطار بعد مراوغه
قوات الامن التي سمحت لهم بالدخول ظنا
انهم من المسافرين لم تعرف لهذه المظاهرات
فقط رحله 60 الف اسرائيلي سيسافرون من
مطار بن غوريون اليوم انما عرقلت زياره
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
مرتين الى اسرائيل حيث قرر اجراء اللقاءات
مع صانعي القرار قرب المطار دون الدخول
الى البلاد ومن المتوقع ان تستمر هذه
المظاهرات طالما ان الحكومه مستمره في
الانقلاب على القضاء لا نقول غاسي في
المطار بن غوريون العربيه
ولنا في الغاز تنضم الينا الان مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك لنا من حيث انت انقلي لنا
المشهد ونحن بحسب ما افهم بانتظار مؤتمر
صحفي لوزير الدفاع الامريكي ونظير
الاسرائيلي
اهلا بك صحيح يعني نحن الان نتواجد في
القدس منذ صباح اليوم كان هناك عشرات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين الذين خرجوا
للتظاهر ضد ما يعرف بالتغييرات القضائيه
يعني وازداد او ما يغضب فعليا المتظاهرين
اليوم هو قرار رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي هو
وزوجته الخروج الى عطل العطله فعليه عطله
نهايه الاسبوع الى ايطاليا وهذا ما يغضب
المتظاهرين حيث قالوا ان البلاد تشتعل
البلاد في وضع غير مستقر ورئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو بدلا من
محاوله تهدئه الاوضاع هو يخرج مع زوجته
الى الى ايطاليا وفعليا منذ صباح اليوم
كان هناك اغلاق لا عدد كبير من الطرق
الرئيسه في اسرائيل في تل ابيب في القدس
وايضا في بئر السبع وحيفا نحن نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره ولاول مره المتظاهرون ايضا
يعني لا يتعلق الموضوع فقط عن ايام العطله
هم يخرجون الان في وسط الاسبوع ويتوجهون
اليوم لاول مره في مطار بن غوريون الدولي
حيث عطلوا يعني اكثر من 60 الف مسافر
اسرائيل
ارادوا ان
يسافروا عبر بن غريون الدولي طيب لنا رغم
ذلك نتنياهو ذهب الى ايطاليا استقل طائره
مروحيه للوصول الى المطار وبالتالي غير
معني بتحرك الشارع
يعني صحيح هو فعليا حاول حاول المتظاهرون
ان يمنعوا او يحاولوا منع فعليا توجه
بنيامين نتنياهو وزوجته الى ايطاليا ولكن
بالرغم من هذه المحاولات واغلاق للطرق هو
استخدم طائره خاصه ومروحه او هليكوبتر حيث
نقلته من القدس الى مطار بن غريون ومن ثم
سوف يتوجه الى فعليا الى ايطاليا وفي
المطار كان هناك ايضا مقابله اجريت مع
بنيامين نتنياهو حيث قال بان فعليا هذه
هذه الاحتجاجات هي لا تتعلق فقط في موضوع
القضاء وانما يريد المعارضه اسقاط هذه
الحكومه التي تم انتخابها عن طريق
انتخابات ديمقراطيه وهم يريدون يعني
يريدون اسقاط فعليا هذه الحكومه الجديده
ويريدون التوجه الى
الى انتخابات سعد سادسه ويعني يدعي نت
بانه هو يحاول ان يهدئ الوضع ولكن
المعارضه هي يعني يتهم المعارضه بان هي من
تخلق هذه الفوضى وهي تتسبب في يعني تحويل
الشارع الاسرائيلي الى فوضى وربما سوف
يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى انقلاب عسكري
ايضا شاهدنا يعني هناك انضمام اعداد من
جنود الاحتياط الى هذه المظاهرات وهذا ما
يقلق ايضا اسرائيل يقلق اسرائيل وربما
يحرجها ايضا امام المجتمع الدولي اضطر
للقاء وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وزير الدفاع
عذرا الامريكي في المطار كيف نتوقع ان
يكون التعاطي مع الداخل والى اي حد هذا
الاحراج يمكن له ان يدفع هذه الحكومه
لتغيير مواقفها على المستوى ضغوط خارجيه
ومنها الامريكيه
يعني على ما يبدو ان نتنياهو فعليا هو
متمسك بجميع القرارات وبالرغم من وجود
هناك يعني عشرات الالاف من المتظاهرين
الذين يستمرون في التظاهر للاسبوع العاشر
على التوالي الا ان نتنياهو وحكومته تصر
على موقفها وفعليا يعني بالرغم من ان
البلاد تشتعل وحتى المتظاهرين قالوا ان
البلاد تشتعل ان الاوضاع غير مستقره
ويخرج في عطله في فعليا مع زوجته فيعني
حتى الضغوطات الامريكيه حتى ايضا شاهدنا
ما حصل في العقبه عندما تواجد الجانب
الاسرائيلي والجانب الامريكي وايضا
الفلسطيني والاردني حيث اكدوا انه يجب ان
يعني اسرائيل ان تحاول تهدئه الاوضاع يعني
خاصه في القدس والضفه الغربيه ولكن بعد
ذلك يعني شاهدنا عدم التزام اسرائيل في اي
من
قراراتها او حتى تصريحاتها فيعني نحن
نتحدث عن حكومه هي يعني لا تهتم
بالداخل ولا الخارج ولا اي حكومه على
يعاين لنتابع التطورات نعم من القدس
مراسلات العربيه لا نقاصي شكرا جزيلا لك
حول التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه قتلت
القوات الاسرائيليه ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين
في بلده جبعا جنوبي مخيم جنين صباح اليوم
افاد مراسل العربيه بان القوات
الاسرائيليه اقتحمت البلده نشرت القناصه
على اسطح المنازل وسط الشبكات عنيفه نتابع
قوات خاصه
هاي السياره هونداي اكسنت
الى مصر الان حيث قال الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ان الحرب على الارهاب لم
تكن سهله كما كشف السيسي عن موافقه
اسرائيل منذ العام 2011 على زياده القوات
المصريه في سيناء لمكافحه الارهاب
كان القرار ساعتها من
من سياده المشير ان احنا ندخل بقوات عملنا
الاجراءات المطلوبه مع
الاسرائيليين في الوقت دوت
واتصلت بيهم قلت له احنا محتاجين ندخل
قوات دلوقتي في المنطقه في العريش ورفح
والشيخ زويد عشان
نسيطر على الموقف هناك الحقيقه عشان ده
بسجله للتاريخ يعني ان هم كانوا متفاهمين
ده
كانوا متفاهمين ده وما كانوش يعني الحقيقه
كانوا قالوا يعني
بس ادينا خبر القوات اللي هتبقى موجوده قد
ايه
ونسقه معنا يعني
واستمرينا من الوقت دوت لغايه يمكن لغايه
دلوقتي بس يمكن حجم القوات اللي كان موجود
[موسيقى]
خلال
التمن تسع سنين دول
من 2011 لغايه النهارده
زادت القوات كل مره عشان
نتعامل مع التحديات اللي موجوده هناك
الرئيس المصري قال ان هناك فيلم يوثق
لفضائع ارتكبها الارهابيون قد لا ينام
المصريون اذا شاهدوه على حد تعبيره
انا والله لولا رافه بكم
اوريكم فيلم واحد
والله العظيم
انا بقسم بالله
انا متهيا لي كل المصريين مع هتنام لو
اذعت لكم الفيلم ده
على اللي كانوا بيعملوه وده متصور
ناقش وزير العدل المغربي عبد اللطيف وهبي
مع رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني توقيع اتفاقيه قضائيه تمهد
الطريق لتسلم المغرب عددا من مغاربه تنظيم
داعش المعتقلين لدى السلطات العراقيه
السوداني اكد من جانبه اهميه تعزيز
الشراكه وتوطيد التعاون بين البلدين في
المجال القانوني والقضاء فضلا عن البرامج
المشتركه في التدريب القانوني وتبادل
المعلومات في الجانب الامني كانت اللجنه
الخارجيه في البرلمان المغربي اشارت الى
ان ما لا يقل عن
1370 مغربيا انضموا لحركات ارهابيه في
العراق وسوريا
الى جورجيا فمع استمرار حده الاحتجاجات في
جورجيا طبعا بسبب مشروع قانون يهدد عمل
وسائل الاعلام والمنظمات غير الحكوميه
اعلنت احزاب المعارضه انها ستواصل
للاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه كما طلبت المعارضه
بالافراج عن عشرات المحتجين المعتقلين من
قبل القوات الامنيه جاء ذلك ردا على قرار
الحزب الحاكم بسحب القانون من البرلمان
الحزب اعتبر ان مشروع القانون تم تقديمه
بطريقه مضلله متعهدا باجراء مشاورات عامه
لتقديم شرح افضل لمشروع القانون لاحقا هذا
ورحب وفض الاتحاد الاوروبي الى جورجيا
بالاعلان عن سحب مشروع القانون حتى القاده
السياسيين على استئناف الاصلاحات المؤديه
للديمقراطيه
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات نحن بحاجه الى طرح هذا القانون على
الجلسه البرلمانيه المكتمله والغائه بشكل
رسمي
في هذه الاثناء باتت جورجيا مكانا للتصعيد
بين موسكو واشنطن واوروبا من جهه حيث اتهم
رئيس لجنه التشريع الدستوري بمجلس الاتحاد
الروسي اتهم الولايات المتحده تم ايضا
الاتحاد الاوروبي بمحاوله تنفيذ انقلاب
غير دستوري في جورجيا اعتبر ايضا ان قرار
الانقلاب الذي وصفه بالمدبر هو رد على
محاوله جورجيا فهم ما يحدث في اطار
التمويل الاجنبي للعديد من المنظمات غير
الحكوميه على اراضيها وفق قوله
لكن لماذا كل هذا الخلاف حول مشروع
القانون مشروع القانون المعروف باسم
الوكلاء الاجانب اثاره اضرابات واسعه
وتطورت الاشتباكات عنيفه مع الشرطه في
اعقاب اقرار قراءته الاوليه من البرلمان
رغم قرار سحبه من البرلمان في محاوله طبعا
لتهدئه الراي العام لم يغلق حزب الحلم
الجمهوري او جورج عذرا الحاكم لم يغلق
الباب وبالكامل امام عودته مستقبلا هذا
القانون المثير للجدل يهدف الى الكشف عن
تدفقات الاموال القادمه من الخارج حيث
يلزم اي منظمه تتلقى اكثر من 20% من
تمويلها من خارج البلاد بان تسجل نفسها
على انها ضمن الوكلاء الاجانب والا ستواجه
غرامات قد تصل الى حوالي عشره الاف دولار
امريكي طبعا تعتبر وزاره العدل التشريعي
يستهدف كشف تاثير العملاء الاجانب في
البلاد يرى مؤيد ان الولايات المتحده
لديها قانون مشابه وهو قانون تسجيل
العملاء الاجانب في المقابل يرى معارضون
تشريعا انه تقليد لروسيا وما تنتهجه من
تضييق على حريه التعبير والاعلام كما
يعتبرونه اشاره الى ان النفوذ الروسي في
جورجيا بدا يتزايد الاهم من ذلك من وجهه
نظر معارضيها انه يقلل من فرص انضمام
جورجيا للاتحاد الاوروبي ففي السنوات
الماضيه واجهت ابليس انتقادات متزايده
بشان ما يعتقد انه تراجع عن الديمقراطيه
ما اساء للعلاقات مع بروكسل واشنطن دخلت
على خط الازمه حيث عبرت عن قلقها ازاء
القانون دعت السلطات الاحترام المظاهرات
السلميه وحريه التعبير والاحتجاج
وصفت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج استحواذ استراليا على
غواصه نوويه من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا بالانتشار النووي الخطير داعيه
الدول الثلاث الى التخلي عن عقليه الحرب
البارده على حد وصفها
فيما يتعلق بالتعاون بين الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا واستراليا بشان الغواصه النوويه
فالصين اعلنت مرارا موقفها الرسمي نعتقد
ان التعاون بين دول الثلاث يشكل انتشارا
نوويا خطيرا ويؤثر على النظام الدولي في
سياسه عدم انتشار النووي ويحفز سباق
التسلح ويقوض السلامه والاستقرار في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ كما ان هذا الامر
يقابل بمعارضه على نطاق واسع من قبل دول
المنطقه والمجتمع الدوليه نحث الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا على التخلي
عن عقليه الحرب البارده والوفاء باخلاص
بالتزاماتها الدوليه وبذل المزيد للاسهام
في السلامه والاستقرار الدوليين
والى توترات جراء التجارب الصاروخيه اعلن
جيش كوريا الجنوبيه ان كوريا الشماليه
اطلقت صاروخا باليستيا قصير المدى باتجاه
البحر الاصفر في خطوه من شانها تاجيج
الصراع الحاصل اصلا بين الدولتين جاء هذا
في وقت توقع فيه تقرير للاستخبارات
الامريكيه توقع ان تجري كوريا الشماليه
تجري اختبارات نوويه اخرى في اطار جهود
زعيمها كيم جونغ اون لبناء رسانه النوويه
من المرجح ان يستمر كيم جونغ اون في اطلاق
الصواريخ ذات القدرات النوويه في محاوله
لتطبيع اختبارات صواريخ
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
لطمانه السلطات باوروبا تيك توك ستبدا في
تخزين بيانات المستخدمين محليا بدءا من
العام الجاري
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكمل من تونس
حيث اعلن الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد خلال
انعقاد مجلس الوزراء اعلن ان المجلس ينظر
في دعوه البرلمان للانعقاد في موعده مشيرا
الى احترام المواعيد الدستوريه سواء بوضع
الدستور او تنظيم الاستفتاء او تنظيم
انتخابات اعضاء مجلس نواب الشعب نتابع
وسيتم النظر
في هذا المجلس
في عدد من مشاريع النصوص
اولها
الامر المتعلق
بدعوه اعضاء مجلس النواب للانعقاد
لاننا احترمنا
المواعيد كلها
ونحترم
المواعيد
التي قطعناها
في تونس ايضا اعلنت اداره الحرس الوطني
التونسي انتشاله اربع عشره جثه وانقاذ 54
مهاجرا غير قانونيين بعد غرق قاربهم قرب
سواحل صفاقس قالت الاداره في بيان ان
القارب كان يحمل مهاجرين افارقه مشيره الى
وقوع الحادث الليله الماضيه امام سواحل
ولايه صفاقس
الى فرنسا الان وردا على تمرير قانون رفع
سن التقاعد بمجلس الشيوخ رغم الاعتراضات
عليه ينظم العمال في العديد من القطاعات
الخدميه موجه جديده من الاضرابات ضد خطه
الحكومه لاقرار هذا المشروع من المقرر ان
تتعطل شبكه السكك الحديديه وايضا الحركه
الجويه
اذا رغم الاحتجاجات والاضرابات وحتى
التهديد الان بالاستمرار يبدو ان خطه
حكومه الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون لاقرار هذا
المشروع مشروع قانون لتعديل نظام التقاعد
المثير للجدل في طريقها للاقرار اولى هذه
الخطوات جاءت بتمرير مجلس الشيوخ ماده
رئيسيه في مشروع القانون تنصه على رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما وذلك رغم معركه
اجرائيه حاده مع اليسار
من الاعضاء صوتوا لصالح رفع سن التقاعد
مقابل 115 عضوا صوت ضده وينصه مشروع
القانون على زياده مده الاشتراكات
المطلوبه في الضمان الاجتماعي من 42 عام
الى 43 عام لكي يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه
التقاعدي كاملا دون اي خصومات يقول
برلمانيون انه من المتوقع ووفقا لخطه
الحكومه ان يمرر البرلمان هذا القانون
بحلول السادس عشر من الشهر الجاري وقد
وصفت رئيسه الوزراء مشروع القانون
بالمتوازن والعادل حيث تعول حكومتها على
هذا الاصلاح لضمان تمويل نظام الضمان
الاجتماعي الذي يشكل احد ركائز النموذج
الاجتماعي الفرنسي وضمان عدم افلاسه فيما
تظهر الاستطلاعات ان غالبيه الفرنسيين
يعارضون الاصلاح ويصفونه بالظالم فيما دعت
النقابات العماليه
الى الانص ات الى رفض الشارع مهدده بمزيد
من الاضطرابات حتى العدول عن القانون
ونبقى في فرنسا حيث ارتفع معدل التضخم مره
اخرى بسبب تسارع مستمر في ارتفاع اسعار
المواد الغذائيه والخدمات وفقا لتقديرات
المعهد الوطني للاحصاء ووسطى سقط الشارع
الفرنسي توصلت الحكومه الى اتفاق مع كبار
الموردين لانشاء صله الغذائيه لمكافحه
التضخم
القدره الشرائيه للمواطن الفرنسي بدت على
المحاك بعدما رفع تضخم من جديد اسعار
المواد الاساسيه وبهدف تخفيف هذه الصدمه
على المستهلكين تدخلت الحكومه ونجحت بعد
مفاوضات طويله مع كبار الموزعين في
اقناعهم بانشاء سله غذائيه لمكافحه التضخم
اسعار المواد الغذائيه باتت مصدر قلق
المواطن الفرنسي بعدما ارتفع معدل التضخم
وتجاوز السته في المئه فمع استمرار هذه
الازمه لم يعد بمقدور المستهلكين تحمل
المزيد من الغلاء كحال هذه الطالبه التي
تعيش في باريس وتعاني من ازمه التضخم
قبل ما كنت انتبه على الاسعار لما اشتري
واحط الاغراض مثل المواد الغذائيه هلا صرت
انتبه على كل شغله يعني مثلا باخذ
المرتديلا صرت انتبه على قديش صار سعرها
فالاسعار كتير غليت نسبه من قبل لهلا
فاختلفت الحياه فعليا عليك
اصحاب المتاجر الصغيره ايضا يتكبدون خسائر
كبيره نتيجه التضخم ويطالبون الحكومه
بتخفيف الضغط عليهم
منذ عام حدث تبدل هائل بالاسعار مثلا
الخضار المجففه ارتفع سعرها تقريبا 10 او
15% لم يعد الناس يستطيعون تناول الطعام
كما كانوا من قبل فالاسعار باهظه سابقا
كانوا يخزنون المواد الغذائيه في منازلهم
لكنهم اليوم يشترون ما يحتاجونه ليوم واحد
فقط
ولمواجهه هذه الازمه سارعت السلطات الى
التدخل وضغطت على كبار الموزعين لانشاء
سلال من المنتجات الغذائيه وبيعها باقل
تكلفه مع تثبيت اسعارها
المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
ونظيره الاسرائيلي
القوي الذي يجمع بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده
العلاقه الاستراتيجيه بين بلدينا
وعمق وعمقها في ظل قيادتكم وتعاونكم قد
وصل الى مستويات كبيره
واضربوا مثالين اهمهما هو مساله تحويل
الطرق العمل المشتركه والتدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه المستمره هذه العلاقه الضروريه
لاستقرار المنطقه
وللامن دوله اسرائيل وهذا يشمل ضمن اشعه
اخرى
تفوق اسرائيل عسكريا في المنطقه اليوم
نجد انفسنا في مرحله حرجه من الوقت ففي
الفتره القادمه سوف نجتمع
من اجل
اتخاذ قرارات الحاسمه ومهمه ايران ترمي
الى الحصول على سلاح نووي
وتهديد ليس اسرائيل فقط بل العالم باسره
سعاده الوزير
انه من واجبنا ان نتخذ كافه التدابير
الضروريه من اجل منعه ايران من الحصول على
سلاح نووي وفي هذا السياق فان قدراتنا
وتعاوننا
سوف يكون له مخزن كبير
واننا
نكرس وقد درسنا جزءا كبيرا من اجتمعنا
اليوم لمناقشه بعض المجالات المتعلقه
بالتعاون الدفاعي
النووي يتطلب منا ان نكون على اهبه
الاستعداد لاي اجراء ولاي احتمال وانني
اؤكد واشدد مجددا لابد لنا ان نكون على
اهبه الاستعداد
لكل عمل محتمل اذا ما حصلت ايرا على سلاح
نووي
وقدره الردع النووي فان نظام ايه الله
لن يكون ذلك بالنسبه لنا مقبولا وخاصه في
ظل ما يقوم به في
دعم دعم حزب الله ودعم لروسيا بالمسيرات
نرى عمليه الارهاب التي تطال الابرياء في
كافه المنطقه بما في ذلك الشعب الايراني
الذي يعاني
من القبضه القمعيه للنظام في طهران
سعاده الوزير
بصفتنا ابناء بصفه ابن لمحرقه الهولوك
كوست فانني اتحمل هذه المسؤوليه على عاتقه
ويجب ان نفعل كل شيء ضمن قدرتنا
لنتاكد بان
نكون حازمين
واقوياء في التصدي لذلك
الوزير اوستن
اسمح لي
في هذه المناسبه ان اعبر عن امتنانه وشكري
نيابه عن مؤسسه الدفاع الاسرائيليه
لالتزامكم الشخصي الذي لا يهز الذي لا يهز
والذي يجمع العلاقه في بين بلدينا وانني
اتطلع للمزيد من العمل معكم بصوره لسيقه
اليوم
قد اظهرنا لاصدقائنا واعدائنا على حد سوا
انه
ابتداء من اصغر شاب عسكري الى اكبر قياده
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده تقفان مع بعضهم
البعض
سعاده الوزير
اسعد الله اوقاتكم جميعا
يسعدني ان اكون في اسرائيل مجددا السيد
قال انت شكرا على هذا الاجتماع المثمر لقد
تحدثنا في اكثر من مناسبه عبر الهاتف لكنه
امر رائع ان اكون هنا شخصيا واتحدث اليكم
وسبب وجودي هنا هو لنقل رساله واضحه فان
التزام امريكا بامن اسرائيل
هي هو التزام صلب ولن يهز
وكما قال الرئيس بايدن خلال زيارته
لاسرائيل في العمل الماضي ان الرابط بين
الشعب الاسرائيلي والشعب الامريكي هو هو
ارتباط عميق
اسرائيل هي شريك استراتيجي اساسي للولايات
المتحده
واعطاء هذه العلاقه الخاصه كانت قد بدات
عندما اصبح الرئيس سترومان هو زعيم الاول
الذي اعترف بدوله اسرائيل
وبعد ان تم تاسيسها ب 11 دقيقه وهذا
ياخذنا بالتاريخ الى ما حدث في تركيا
سنوات ان علاقتنا لا تعتمد فقط على
المصالح المشتركه بل هي
متينه في بقيم الديمقراطيه والحريه وسياده
القانون
وهذه القيم تبقى ضروريه
وكما ذكر الرئيس بايدن ان
عبقريه الديمقراطيه الامريكيه وعبقريه
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه
تتمثل بانهما مؤسسات مؤسسات قويه تعتمد
على التحقيق
والتوازن وعلى وجود سلطه قضائيه مستقله
وقد اشار الرئيس ان بناء الاجماع بالنسبه
لاجراء تغيرات اساسيه فمن الضروره ان
نتاكد ان الشعب سوف
يتبنى تلك التغييرات بحيث يتم
الالتزام بها على مر
الاجيال وسنوات عملت الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل
لتوطيد هذه العلاقه فيمكنكم ان تروا مدى
عمق العلاقه الامنيه مع اسرائيل
والمساعدات الكبيره التي تقدمها الولايات
المتحده لاسرائيل ان مذكره التفاهم
التاريخيه الخاصه بنا تقدم فاصل ثلاثه
مليار دولار سنويا من قبيل المساعدات
العسكريه بالاضافه الى تمويل اضافي في
مجال التعاون
الدفاعي صاروخي وانني فخور بان الرئيس
بادي كان قد عبر عن دعمه لمذاكره التفاهم
وفي السنه الماضيه كان كان هناك اعلان
القدس التاريخي وفي هذا الاعلان تم
التاكيد مجددا على التزام اسرائيل بامن
على التزامي الولايات المتحده بامن
اسرائيل ويمكنكم ان تروا التزامنا قد تمثل
في العمليات العسكريه المشتركه التي قمنا
بها سويه
بالاضافه الى عدد من القوات الاسرائيليه
وقد شاركنا سويه
في مع وجود الجيل الخامس من
المعدات العسكريه المتطوره بالاضافه الى
عدد كبير من الطائرات كان تمرينا طموحا
للغايه
وناجحا للغايه
وهذا يعزز ويصلط الضوء على على عمق
العلاقه وهي خطوه اساسيه نحو الامام في
تعزيز قدراتنا الامر الذي يساعدنا على
التصدي للتهديدات الاقليميه ويظهر مدى
قدراتنا على نشر القوات بسرعه استجابه لاي
ازمات رغم اننا سوف نحافظ على التزاماتنا
في مجالات اخرى قطعنا وعود بها وكما
تتوقعون وسمعتم ما قاله الوزير ان جلان
النقاشاتنا اليوم كانت قد دارت حول
التهديدات الاتيه من ايران ايران تبقى هي
المحرك الرئيسي لعدم الاستقرار في المنطقه
ونحن سوف نبقى نشعر بالغ القلق ازاء تهديد
ايران للارهاب وكلائها الخاطرين
ايضا مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من مؤتمر
الصحفي لوزير الدفاع الامريكي مع نظيره
الاسرائيلي وننهي بان منصه تيك توك قالت
بانه سيتم تخزين بيانات مستخدميها ابتداء
من هذا العام في الداخل الاوروبي شكرا
للمتابعه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا